this is a premium Wagyu steak from Japan
and costs around $100 at supermarkets in
the US and this is also Wagyu but it
costs $40 that's because it comes from
here the vast country of Australia where
ranchers are racing ahead to win the
global market for Wagyu by experimenting
with different methods to raise the
cattle we're running about 2,000 ragged
cattle the wages have been the lynchpin
for our growth as a business all this
doesn't sit well with Japanese farmers
[Music]
Japan and Australia are the biggest
Wagyu producers in the world and they're
vying for the largest export market that
is the u.s. by 2023 the global Wagyu
industry will generate sales of around
nine point five billion dollars
according to the market research firm
technoboy so whilst ralien and Japanese
farmers are in an intense competition
with one country betting on traditional
the other is betting on new technology
to increase productivity we are mapping
the entire j9l know whether to breed on
from it or it's going to end up on the
dinner plate so this is really powerful
technology and we're using it to full
effective Wagyu is a breed of cattle
native to Japan and literally translates
into Japanese beef what makes it so
special is the high concentration of fat
that's inside the muscles the industry
calls it marbling and that's what farmer
Kazuki Morimoto does best I would have
said some Mayo Clinic's Tomoko did what
I got you saw some deer come and did a
master he says the trick to his success
has been following strict traditions and
it's get more Ji Hoon na kimochi boy
here
Wagyu farms are usually small but
Morimoto's 300 cows have brought in 1.4
million dollars annually in the past few
years a small herd allows him to pay
very close attention to the feed which
accounts for almost 70% of his cause
high karada no naka no Santiago Curtis a
new browser tab my to pronounce Morimoto
usually fattens his cows for a minimum
of two and a half years compared to the
average one and a half years it takes
for other types of cattle like Angus he
says his Wagyu is meant to be consumed
in small quantities similar to other
high-end delicacies like caviar and foie
gras many Australian ranchers see the
Japanese way of raising Baidu as out of
date the Japanese they're feeding the
animals from basically from birth they
just feed feed feed and and we're not
doing that
Steve Binney is part of a new generation
of Wagyu ranchers who want to produce
beef and what he says is the modern way
he had his first Wagyu steak five years
ago some people say where were you when
you know September 11 happened where
were you when Kennedy got shot and so I
look at this moment in my life was when
I had that first Wagyu and it was so
incredible
the next day Benny pivoted his nearly
100 year old family business from
Hereford cattle to Wagyu night to night
strip loin beautiful this is what we'll
be having for lunch
the Australian product does cost less
because we're more efficient we're doing
it on a large scale with low costs of
production
Australian ranchers have perfected a
technology that Japanese farmers like
Morimoto won't ever consider using
agricultural genomics it's the analysis
and selection of the best DNA in Wagyu
cattle benny has been artificially
inseminating his cow since he started
raising Wagyu for this cow he's
carefully selected sperm so that the
resulting calf will thrive in the hot
Australian climate you need less water
and food compared to a cow in Japan but
still grow up to become Wagyu that's
rich in fat it's a very data-driven
process all of the carcasses that are
coming through the abattoir they are
evaluated for amount of marbling weight
age days on feed all of this data is
going into this monstrous database and
all of these carcasses are being linked
back to the genetics using this
Australian ranchers also create cross
breeds with other cows like Angus these
steaks usually have less marbling
because they're genetically 50 percent
Wagyu so about half the price of full
blood Wagyu steak many of these cross
bred Wagyu steaks end up on plates in
the US where local Wagyu production
makes up a tiny portion of the larger
cattle industry by 2021 benny expects to
increase his sales to the US by up to
50%
[Music]
Wagyu embryos first arrived in Australia
in the early 1990s but the combination
of genomics and Australia's ability to
scale cheaper Wagyu production has led
to a boom in demand helping the
Australian industry grow by 20% every
year since 2015 last year
country sold 40,000 tons of Wagyu beef
abroad making it the largest exporter of
the steaks on the planet by volume well
ahead of Japan's export of just 4,300
tons
farmers like Morimoto have been feeling
the market gets sucked away from them by
Australian ranchers so the Japanese
government has stepped in to protect and
promote its Wagyu industry action houses
like this one are the only places where
Japanese farmers can sell their Wagyu
beef for years these places were not
allowed to sell to the u.s. a coveted
market for Wagyu farmers the last year
Japan signed a key trade deal with the
u.s. to export unlimited Wagyu a key
part of the Japanese government's grand
strategy to double beef exports
the government also recently passed a
bill that criminalizes the export of
Wagyu semen and embryos but experts say
these reforms don't really get at the
heart of the issue with japan's industry
security of a Wagyu original beef is a
very excellent but a crises too
expensive takafumi godo
is an agronomist who studies the Wagyu
beef industry he says that in order for
Japanese farmers to catch up they need
to start copying what Australian
ranchers are doing produce Wagyu beef
that's less rich in fat and therefore
cheaper Australian farmers consider the
business for the Japanese farmers the
most important thing is to produce good
modernity German farmer should do
easiness consider the cost of four whole
months how much feed how much profit but
that would be something Japanese
ranchers will accept easily
pedometer toys show me the quarter the
map oh that's that's got a blog yeah you
cannot dance to those listening
mookaite a potato this is an eye for
Miyazaki ribeye from Japan and here we
have a beautiful Australian ribeye